j'ai pas la télé mais je vais très bien
comme ça tu as pas internet pas la télé
c'est ça je me suis rendu compte que la
télé ça me bouffait trop c'est à dire
que je l'allumé et voilà je voyais les
horaires dans le monde et ça me ça me
chamboulait trop ça t'es trop trop
émotive et regardez ces images
inquiétantes de la canicule extrême qui
touche à peu près tous les mystère nord
de la planète en Chine la région du
cynthiang a enregistré hier une
température de 52,2 degrés à Tokyo 40
degrés les autorités demandent aux
habitants de rentrer chez eux et
d'éviter de faire de l'exercice aux
États-Unis dans la Vallée de la Mort le
thermomètre est monté jusqu'à 56 degrés
quand on parle ce sont des températures
raisonnables mais quand on regarde le
modèle européen qui était établi par
Météo France qui s'appelle arpège
regardez que ce soit sur l'Italie sur la
Sardaigne sur la France sur le sud-est
on pourrait avoir entre 40 et 45 degrés
voire jusqu'à 47 48 en Sardaigne donc
c'est complètement dingue donc au
Vatican la température a atteint les 43
degrés ce week-end la chaleur est énorme
c'est terrible on se rend compte que il
fait plus chaud par rapport à là où nous
restons chez nous en Afrique par exemple
en République démocratique du Congo même
constat en Floride
c'est l'enfer il fait chaud une chaleur
folle je n'ai jamais connu une telle
chaleur
[Musique]
qui vient pour la sorcière on est là
fin en Espagne il y a une Malone
malhonnête et intellectuelle vous êtes
sûr que Serge Zakar qui est là aussi un
docteur en agricole climatologique lui a
répondu il manque des éléments
importants dans ce contexte cette mesure
prise par satellite donne une
information de la température de la
surface du sol elle peut être de 15 à 20
degrés supérieure à l'air suivant le
type de sol et sa couleur il n'a jamais
fait 60 degrés en Espagne c'est insensé
marfeno mars
le ministre de l'Agriculture qui a
déclaré ça il y a quelque chose fais un
peu chaud dans le ministère mais sinon
globalement ça va ça va non mais ça
montre bien le décalage de nos ministres
de l'Agriculture qui évidemment le
ministre on sait de qui les ministres
d'ailleurs plutôt le ministre des
chasseurs et de l'agro-industrie donc
évidemment pour lui tout va bien mais la
situation non mais la situation est
catastrophique
parce que vous
pisser dans un violon voilà un chiffre
et peut-être le chiffre du jour
73% des Français estiment que les
services de renseignement doivent
pouvoir utiliser les mêmes moyens que
l'entité rorrisme pour surveiller et
arrêter les activistes qui comptent
saboter les sites sensibles c'est à dire
que les Français disent les
ecoloradicaux ayant n'a marre la
bienveillance médiatique et politique il
y en a marre cette Français sur 10 que
pompe ton à quelqu'un qu'on enquiquine
Andrea l'air oui
et je me suis retrouvé donc dans ce
restaurant et je suis allé aux toilettes
au pipi room et Johnny s'est retrouvé à
côté de moi et il m'a regardé et puis il
m'a fait et oui Johnny et pipi aussi
et ouais donc c'est un grand moment de
solitude et on a comme ça vous savez une
colorimétrie c'est-à-dire qu'on regarde
en fonction il y a un petit tabac comme
ça le Pantone du pipi exactement c'est
ça alors vous prenez
et voyez quand vous êtes vert un c'est à
dire quand ils sont extrêmement clairs
bah c'est que vous êtes très bien
hydraté le rein relâche l'eau et puis si
vous êtes vers 8 les urines sont
extrêmement foncées ça c'est que vous
êtes totalement déshydraté ça me
rappelle cette histoire de Alain Delon
qui disait ne jamais vouloir aller dans
les toilettes publiques vous la
connaissez histoire non non parce que
chaque fois qu'il s'approchait des
doigts publics le gars qui était à côté
en train de baiser
j'ai confiance en toi
Malte
Malte un pays bah alors Portugal
Slovénie orange perdu allez Naples
[Musique]
c'est la bête noire des pickpockets de
Venise pour la plus de 30 ans que Maria
une italienne fait partie d'un collectif
qui lutte contre les voleurs à la tire
de sa ville
désormais elle l'affiche les pics pocket
sur les réseaux sociaux en diffusant ses
interventions où elle donne de la voix
une méthode devenue virale la preuve
sa phrase culte et détournée et remix
des jeux gonflables en plein cœur de la
cité du docteur hey ma Cavaillon jusque
là rien d'anormal pourtant ces
animations ne sont pas à l'initiative de
la mairie derrière ces installations des
dealers du quartier qui chercheraient à
promouvoir leur point de villes les
habitants qui acceptent de témoigner
anonymement sont abasourdi j'ai vu des
jeux de machins gonflables moi en
passant en voiture je vais des gamins
qui
qui jouait sur le machin gonflable les
habitants du quartier craignent
désormais que les dealers attirent des
enfants toujours plus jeunes afin
d’étendre leur influence je conseille à
tout le monde de vivre un ouvrage de
Didier Fassin qui s'appelle
l'anthropologie de la force des de la
force de l'ordre de la police des
quartiers parce qu'en fait ça résume ce
qui se passe c'est qu'on a des gens qui
ne sont pas du qui ne sont pas des
hommes dans lesquelles ils vont
travailler qu'on leur décrit comme des
zones sauvages ou c'est des zones de
non-droits dans lesquelles ils peuvent
pas mettre les pieds à peu près ce qu'on
lit et ce qu'on peut entendre dans
beaucoup de médias généralistes aussi et
ce que je déplore les riverains parlent
de territoires abandonnés par la
République les parrains pensent que
c'est offert par la mairie organisé par
la mairie alors que la mairie elle est
même pas au courant de ça d'ailleurs la
mairie elle met pas un pied au quartier
toutefois interpellé le maire de la
ville a demandé l'ouverture d'une
enquête sur ses installations c'est de
manière effectivement la police
nationale elle est sur place faire des
contrats d'identité savoir quel était
ces personnes sur le terrain qui
apparemment étaient un gardiennage de
ces piscines et de ses jeux aquatiques
dès le départ c'est biaisé parce qu'ils
arrivent dans un endroit où ils partent
avec des a priori négatifs alors que si
ils avaient je pense que il y aurait des
choses à faire entre les jeunes et les
forces de l'ordre pour avoir un sort de
de dialogue qui se crée dès le plus
jeune âge pour les pour les plus jeunes
et dès le début de la formation et de
l'expérience policière pour les pour les
policiers parce que du coup en fait ça
ça désamorcerait beaucoup de choses qui
peuvent se passer autant chez les jeunes
que chez les policiers et je pense que
vraiment enfin le monde de toute façon
ne peut bouger que parler l'éducation et
la formation etc c'est on se prend une
photo dans notre meilleur jour on est
bien maquillé on est bien coiffé mais en
fait au fond de nous on est on sait plus
qui on est on sait pas qu'est-ce qu'on
est est-ce qu'on se plaît nous en fait
pour toi une clé importante ça a été de
couper certaines relations de couper
certains médias exactement mais je me
rendais pas compte qu'en fait moi-même
je pouvais changer le truc je me suis
rendu compte qu'en fait en coupant tout
ça mes cheveux me retrouver moi-même
dans mon existence moi je suis sur terre
et je lui dis pour moi